you
got a job at the playboy mansion
yes i was a butler for hugh hefner
for one year
and
and um
i saw stuff
he did
now you told uh you told us a story and
uh yeah that was the first day on
you know my of my job
uh i got the job wait how do you get the
job okay i got the job i was taking an
acting class with gordon hunt and one of
the people in the class was zelda
rubenstein who right around that time
got the job as the medium in um
uh
poltergeist oh the little the little
lady
and so she
so she knew that i needed another
part-time job and she said i know the
head butler at the playboy mansion so
she introduced me to him wait was uh
zelda rubenstein also a playmate no she
was not okay
she was not
you could put up a picture of zelda
rubenstein right now jeremy um so people
can
so zelda
introduced me to them they i went in and
and met with them they asked who is they
had butler who was the head butler his
name was thomas i don't remember his
last name as the head butler at the uh
playboy mansion is that the person in
charge or were they in charge of there
were people in charge of him
no
no they were in charge there were people
in charge of him so i met with his boss
who was mary something i don't remember
her last name right now and she
uh asked me you know if i'm if i've ever
been in a service position and i said no
and she asked me if um
i
had a black vest and i said no and she
asked me if i was comfortable with
different kinds of people and i said yes
and then in that order those were the
questions have you been in the service
business do you have a black vest
and are you comfortable with different
kinds of people i don't remember if
there was any other
questions but those were the main things
when i drove home thinking this is what
we covered
go ahead
yeah so you get home and did you did she
tell you in the room that you had the
job yeah
okay she asked me if i could be there
friday mm-hmm what day of the week was
it i don't remember okay but you do
remember what day you had to be there
yeah i remember i had to be there on a
friday night and i worked friday and
saturday and sunday
for shabbat yes so so uh friday night so
you went out you bought a vest and black
pants and black pants i had black shoes
howie
i didn't ask well
just so you know okay and uh my first
one of my first tasks i remember i
so you get there the head butler gives
me you know takes me around he's showing
me how to you know fill up the m m jars
and make sure there's baby oil in every
bathroom and you know why did they want
baby oil well it was a different time
howie okay
um
and um then
i just remember he handed me a tray with
two enemas and two douches on it and
said
take this up to bedroom four and you
have never let me so you have two
douches and two enemas
and you've never been in the service
industry before now
and you're wearing a brand new stuck to
it like that wow
okay so you head up i wanna is it on a
silver tray is that how it's presented
it was i don't remember what the tray
looked like i really don't but it was a
tray okay remember that and you knock on
the doors there are buttons there i
knocked on the door but i remember going
through the great hall and going up the
stairs
well it's just big okay that's what they
call it okay um and how many bedrooms
are there i'd imagine like the sistine
chapel like those hallways are great and
grand and big is it like the sistine
chapel well it's kind of more like when
you look at a house and they say this is
the great room and usually it's like a
big room
okay
more like that i wouldn't think of it
more like the sistine chapel that that's
a whole different level
yeah
so uh how many bedrooms are there i
don't remember but this is bedroom four
this was bedroom four go ahead
and i
knock on the door and
um
and it opens and it's uh
um
yeah
very hairy um
[Music]
uh from
uh yeah jim james khan james khan who is
no longer with us that's right
and there were two young girls in the
beginning you know he died do you know
what he did i do know that okay yes
um and
but i didn't really know him did you
know he was going to die
no i didn't know he was going to die dad
we're all going to die well we're all
going to die but we don't know
you know was it was he dressed you're
saying he's very very guess though
you try to guess when people are dead or
going to die is what you do right
i try to guess when they're going to die
oh because no no that was just
what we call an unfortunate incident
okay wait we're calling the fact that
you think my mother passed an
unfortunate
the fact that you're standing with a
douche and an enema in front of was two
douches and two enemies was it was it
was james naked no he was in a white
towel very hairy chest
and i gave him the
tray how do you serve uh sir here's your
deuce i just looked at him i remember
feeling like oh like oh my gosh this is
james connor i handed a tray was it
rollerball yes and then
he i went down to the
pantry and i said to the head butler
do you know who that was in bedroom four
and he said yeah
jimmy likes his girls clean
and
so whenever i would see james khan in
movies like when i was in mid when i was
in the theater watching misery i just
remember
wanting to say to people
fun fact
um
jimmy likes his girls clean like what do
you do with that information you just
kind of carry it with you in your head
and now show them we shared it with
everyone
so
so he the girls douche and is there a
bathroom in bedroom four or there's
i would imagine a bed a bathroom in
every bedroom
i don't know i don't know
you've been to the playboy mansion i
have i was never in bedroom four and i
like everyone clean
yeah i i know that i know that about you
but i've never had them i've told them
to go wash their hands i never said you
know flush out your
ass could you flush out your ass before
you shake my hand i've never said that
to anyone
well i don't know how honestly that how
that discussion
you know comes up um but i would imagine
it would be
i don't know i don't know how he brings
but i'm sure that by the time i saw him
it you know he had a whole system of how
he would handle that oh so he had two
was there two women there were two young
women
and uh
so he would say you know what i'm gonna
do to you
you know what i'm gonna do to you too
and but first you know what you need to
do to yourself
i don't know this is something that you
can roll around in your head when you're
falling asleep
tonight in bed thinking about you know
what you've learned today did you ever
have to do something did you ever have
to do this guys i don't know i come here
and i cough all the time no you always
cough
[Music]